oh hi you know sequels are something
that we're always going to have in the
game industry we're just gonna have to
get used to it in fact it's all we have
for you at all this week on game life so
if you're a fan of the sly cooper dead
space or Fire Emblem series well great
you'll find a new version of those games
on store shelves this week if you're
looking for something entirely new
you'll have to keep your pants on in
fact please just just keep keep your
pants on in general Fire Emblem
awakening is the first three BS entry in
Nintendo's very very long running
tactical strategy war game series put
together your army of anime styled
characters and fight for peace and
justice on a piece of virtual graph
paper awakening has been racking up rave
reviews including one from game life
zone contributor john mix meyer who
writes that this game's new twist namely
the fact that your characters can fall
in love on the battlefield and get
married after it's all over gave him a
much deeper emotional attachment to his
little guys which is all the more
painful since when a character dies in
fire emblem they're dead for good
speaking of which if cats have nine
lives and if squirrels have as many
lives as they think they can get away
with what about raccoons I don't know
the answer to that math problem but I do
know that sly cooper has finally gotten
a new lease on life these platform
action games starring an anthropomorphic
shadow thief and his lovable criminal
pals disappeared after PlayStation 2 but
are now back with Sly Cooper thieves in
time for PlayStation 3 and PlayStation
Vita by the ps3 version you get the vita
game for free and they can share save
data how very convenient finally there's
this week's X Factor dead space 3 I
really enjoyed the first dead space
which was a truly scary truly original
horror game that combined great elements
of Metroid Prime and resident evil 4 but
this third version from what we've seen
so far kind of take
things in a more of a Gears of War
direction with firefights and human
enemies yelling curse words at you
instead of dro tesc aliens just going
like I'm getting your limbs shot often
it also has a cooperative two-player
mode this this doesn't really sound like
the dead space we know and love but
Electronic Arts says it feels it can
broaden the appeal of the series two
more people while retaining the core
fans is this possible read game life
this week and we'll let you know how we
think it turned out that's it for this
week on game life we'll see you next
time